in Iran tens of thousands have taken to
the streets in a massive countrywide
uprising dozens have been killed and
hundreds arrested most demonstrations in
Iran historically have started in the
capital organized by educated upper
middle class and politically active
citizens the protests then spread
outward from there but the most recent
demonstrations started in the east of
the country far from Tehran they then
spread to the rest of the country within
days and they were started by working
middle-class Iranians without a leader
or a set agenda and the match that lit
this fire was something that may
surprise you
the price of eggs Iran was recently hit
with an outbreak of the bird flu which
required them to kill off some 17
million chickens this shortage caused
egg prices to nearly double egg prices
helped spark the uprising but what Iran
ian's are really protesting here is a
series of broken promises by their
president Hassan rouhani
mohamad I'm happy not in Buddhist
together our Kanhaiya PJ isn't much of a
military man oh you're not happiness how
could you when ma honey came into the
presidency in 2013 he pledged to
revitalize the economy he took the first
steps towards doing this in July 2015
when Iran reached a deal to
significantly curb its nuclear program
in exchange the West lifted
international economic sanctions that
had hampered Iran's economy for decades
for a lot of Iranians this symbolized
that Iran was opening up to the world
and it was a reason to celebrate so by
the end of Ronnie's first term he had
achieved some economic success his
policies had brought down the inflation
rate and boosted economic growth but
unemployment and inequality remained
high and foreign investments still
remained low for the working poor Rohan
EES policies made little difference
so when rouhani was back up for election
and made 2017
he vowed to voters that he would make
tangible changes to the economy within
the first hundred days of his new term
mommy cavani daddy
Zamani fruit ah ha ha politics the Saudi
- far babu judo very much he won the
election but the first hundred days came
and went with no real tangible economic
results I as an Iranian I'm frustrated
that government has so many unkept
promises katakan so many problems like
unemployment recession inflation and
social freedom then in December rouhani
published his proposal for his 2018
budget the proposal included plans to
give billions of dollars to
organizations that make up the hardline
religious establishment in Iran the
budget also proposed cutting cash
subsidies to millions of citizens
raising the fuel prices and privatizing
public schools paired with the rising
prices of eggs and other food staples
people around the country especially the
poor and working-class felt betrayed
[Music]
protests erupted quickly turning violent
[Music]
these protesters have no leader no set
agenda they're not driven by political
organizers in the capital but by poor
citizens and villages in rural towns
Iran has a history of massive street
protests transforming its society in
fact the current Islamic Republic of
Iran was born by street protests just
like this these demonstrations began
because of the slow economy and the
price of eggs but they quickly have
morphed into calls for reform and
revolution
[Music]
you